hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys weltweite
gibt es eine motiv torte und zwar backe
ich diesen baumstamm den habe ich schon
auf der internationalen süßwarenmesse
modelliert da habe ich aber nur auf
seinem tod mitgearbeitet mal auf einer
messe kann man keine echten trocken
dekorieren wäre viel zu schade denn man
müsste danach wieder wegschmeißen und
jetzt hab ich gedacht komm ich mach das
jetzt weil viele von euch danach gefragt
haben und im innern dieses kuchens habe
ich eine wickelt orte und wenn man die
dann auf schneidet sie eben auch hübsch
aus sie leben auch fast für baum ähnlich
aus jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
wird es sollte man überhaupt einen
baumstamm backen
die frage habe ich mir auch gestellt
aber da ich mir eingefallen ach kommt
könnte initialen drauf machen kann zum
beispiel die torte zum jahrestag backen
zum hochzeitstag oder warum oder
vatertag fahrertag klingt gut und mit
dem holzfäller ob das kind auch gut wenn
man es auf jeden fall gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene anlässe oder verein findet
ihr noch eine 1 9
ich freue mich ob ich erstmal was der
alles dafür benötigen und starten direkt
also ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal
was ich alles vorbereitet habe und zwar
könnt ihr beim motiv torten immer die
arbeit auf zwei tage eigentlich auf zwei
oder drei tage sogar ich habe gestern
abend bereits die tortenböden gebacken
also den teig gemacht die füllung
vorbereitet und auch die garage gestellt
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier zwei eckige
böden gebacken und zwei runden als er
wickelt orte wird und es ist einfach ein
ganz normaler saftiger kuchen für motiv
torten bei der creme habe ich eine
kaffee buttercreme gemacht also da habe
ich einfach meine deutsche buttercreme
genommen und die abgewandelt und stoff
mädels café genommen und dann habe ich
noch eine weitere nacht gemacht und alle
rezepte findet ihr noch mal verlinkt in
der infobox als video und natürlich auch
auf dem blog jetzt nehme ich mir zuerst
eine runde tortenplatte und zwar ist sie
aus pappe zum cache bord und da streiche
ich jetzt etwas von der weißen kann
drauf da kann nämlich die torten nicht
drauf kutschen das habe ich gleich den
ersten worten würden an und jetzt setze
ich den auf den ersten tortenboden kann
ich das mit der torte zusammenbringt und
es wachsen hier abziehen
ich habe die torten links über nacht
einfach bei raumtemperatur stehen lassen
und habe sie einfach abgedeckt und jetzt
wichtig dass die torte minimal kleiner
ist als der torten rand damit wir später
die torte eben schon glatt streichen
können so jetzt kann ich direkt mit dem
füllen anfangen und damit ich noch etwas
fruchtiges mit dabei habe nämlich noch
etwas pflaumenmus und streicht den jetzt
direkt auf den ersten tortenboden
ihr könnt übrigens einfache arbeiten
wenn ihr die torte auf eine drehbare top
platte habe ich jetzt schon gemacht
nämlich direkt den ersten eckigen boden
und stürzte mit einmal also ich hab ja
noch nicht vorbei kopie runtergezogen so
dafür einfach eine platte obendrauf und
einen token ritter und kann da auch
nichts schief gehen
zumindest in der regel kann ich jetzt is
back micki abziehen
bei diesen wickelt orten ist immer ganz
wichtig dass der teig immer nur kurz und
heiß gebacken wird so bleibt nämlich der
inneren fuhren saftig und reist später
nicht beim wickeln also es wird zwar es
war zwar nicht schlimm aber es bleibt
nämlich schade
jetzt schneide ich diesen tag in
streifen und zwar mache ich dir jetzt
etwa 5 cm breit damit ich später eine
hohe torte bekommen also die böden sind
ja auch in zentimeter breit
jeweils oben unten lässt die torte
insgesamt etwa sieben zentimeter breit
aber ihr könnt ihr natürlich von der
breite her so machen wir jetzt möchte
ich jetzt doch sechs zentimetern ist
etwas höher
dann muss ich das immer mit dem lineal
ab
und da kann ich dir teig streifen mit
einem messer durchschneiden
jetzt kann ich den tortenboden direkt
mit der butter creme bestreichen und
eignet sich eigentlich jede füllung denn
die torte ist er dann von außen mit
diesem biscuit umhüllt und dann könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch eine seine füllung
nehmen
aber ich möchte jetzt später diesen
baumstamm machen und da ist es gut wenn
die torte und ein stabiler ist deswegen
nämlich die buttercreme weil die einfach
etwas fester wird
und wenn ihr hier am rand seiner teig
karte nimmt dann könnte auch hier den
abschluss schön gerade streichen ohne
dass eben was wunder finden wenn ihr
wisst was fragen
und damit ich jetzt aufholen kann und
die teig streifen jetzt nicht kaputt
mache ich noch einmal mit dem messer
entlang also die linie die ich schon
geschnitten habe damit eben die
buttercreme auch durchtrennt wird dann
macht man nämlich nichts kaputt
jetzt kann ich das erste teilstück
aufräumen
und dann kann ich es direkt in die mitte
stellen und der teig ist wirklich sehr
saftig und die nächsten halb ihr zimmer
und nehmen die dann zu hoch denn
ansonsten würden die mir jetzt in der
hand auseinanderbrechen und da kann ich
jetzt immer wieder eine spirale drum
herum legen
und da könnte jetzt eben auch selber
bestimmen wie groß ihr den durchmesser
machen wollt dementsprechend müsst ihr
dann eben den unteren biscuit groß oder
klein backen
fertig mit harter weg ging und setzt
einen tortenring außenrum damit die
torte einfach noch etwas fester wird
unseren bisschen zusammengedrückt wird
dann gehen auch diese zwischenräume weg
mit dieser teig karte kann ich jetzt die
oberfläche noch ein bisschen glatt
streichen so ein bisschen eben machen
denn jetzt kommt noch der teig deckel
drauf aber wenn ihr das extrakt
abgemessen hat dann dürfte eigentlich
fast gut sein wenn ich da auch noch mal
ein bisschen pflaumenmus drauf streichen
jetzt setzt sich noch den deckel drauf
und drücke im schönen glatt fest und da
muss die torte erstmal noch meinen
kühlschrank für mindestens eine stunde
damit die buttercreme festwirt und nicht
daran arbeiten weiter arbeiten kann
und die zwischenzeit werde ich nutzen um
ihre steko herzustellen
naja und die reste die wir hier haben
kann man übrigens als ich habe ein
bisschen buttercreme drin und bis hin zu
und dann kann man auch wirklich anna
schmid dazugeben und ganze zu kugeln
formen in kakao wälzen und dann hat man
so schöne trüffel oder mal verfütterte
einfach an alle die da sind oder man
kann cake pops draus machen oder ein
glas schichten also das ja für meine
ideen in der zwischenzeit möchte ich
jetzt die deko vorbereiten und fahren
möchte ich eine axt auf die torte legen
deswegen mache ich sie jetzt hier aus
neu delhi schokolade dann nehme ich weiß
und damit ich so ein bisschen einfärben
kann dass es eine holz strukturen eine
holz farbe bekommt nämlich noch etwas
schoko fondant und das vermischte kommt
einander
und zwar nämlich seit 200 gramm weiße
modell schokolade und einfach so ein
kleines stückchen braun
das muss ich jetzt erst mal weich kneten
jetzt fahr mich aus diesem hellbraunen
stück eine axt und zwar könnt ihr das
jetzt so in die länge form einfach ein
bisschen rollen und ich finde diese mama
optik darin gar nicht schlecht denn das
soll ja noch holzoptik seit jahrzehnten
ein bisschen dicker und vorne etwas
dünner
jetzt habe ich hier noch 100 gramm rote
modell ihr schokolade und daraus freue
mich jetzt diesen kopf also diesen
scharfen gegenstand an der axt und zwar
müsst ihr das jetzt einfach flach auf
eure oberfläche legen und dann mit den
händen formen
das stellt man zur seite hin ist es
dicker und vorne etwas dünner da kann
man sich jetzt auch hier diese blätter
zu hilfe nehmen
jetzt habe ich die beiden teile krupp
geformt und jetzt muss ich hier noch ein
bisschen struktur einbringen zuerst
einmal schneide ich jetzt hier einen
teil oben weg denn es soll es aussehen
als würde das spiel durch durch diese
klinge durchgehend durch den kopf also
den akt
und jetzt kann ich noch mit hilfe von
etwas modelle werkzeug strukturen
bringen also ein bisschen holzstruktur
aber auch die klinge kann man so ein
bisschen alt wirken lassen und kann da
einfach sowieso was einritzen
und jetzt möchte ich etwas passenden
farbe und zwar gelb schwarz und rot dann
erhalte ich so ein dunkles braun und
kann dann nehme ich den stammen also den
schnee so ein bisschen für magen
und wenn die farbe etwas dünner sein
soll könnte sie mit etwas flüssigem
kamin oder zum beispiel alkohol
verdünnen und noch besser damit malen
an
mit roter und schwarzer pullover farbe
werde ich jetzt noch die klinge bemalen
und etwas silva pulver nehme ich jetzt
noch zum heiraten
jetzt ist die axt fertig bemalt da muss
ich sie noch zusammen kleben und zwar
nehme ich dafür jetzt zwei zahnstocher
ihm die teile noch mal auseinander
ich werde die zweite nur flach auf die
torte legen also man könnte jetzt im
prinzip auch so dann später drauf legen
aber ich möchte lieber trotzdem
miteinander verbinden wenn man die axt
übrigens bereits eine woche vorher zum
beispiel zubereitet dann hätte sie auch
richtig aus dann könnten sie theoretisch
sogar so rein stecken da müssten wir
zwar noch ein paar spitzen machen aber
es wird auf jeden fall funktionieren
wenn ihr ein bisschen essbaren zucker
kleber der kommt jetzt hier rein und
auch auf die andere seite und dann kommt
da einmal ein zahnstocher hier unten ein
da fühlt sich die beiden teile zusammen
und dann nur noch da oben
jetzt kann ich die axt zur seite legen
ein bisschen aushärten lassen und kann
gleich mit der torte weitermachen
die torte sitzt abgekühlt und jetzt kann
ich sie mit der kanal bestreichen
zuerst kommt da jetzt eine dünne schicht
drauf dann gehen wir für 15 minuten im
kühlschrank und dann kommt noch mal die
dickere schicht und die glatte schicht
drauf
die torte sitzt eingedeckt und die muss
jetzt auch nicht perfekt glatt
gestrichen werden da außenrum ihr diese
rinde kommt und alles überdenken würde
und jetzt möchte ich die torte erstmal
eindecken mit vanille von dann habe ich
so eine grundstruktur darunter und dann
kommt eben diese rinde mit drauf der
sieht richtig bruders
so denkt man dann rolle ich jetzt dünn
aus den kann man jetzt auch wirklich ein
bisschen dünner machen
so jetzt kann ich die torte mit etwas
baktrien spray einfetten dann klebte
fondant besser drauf verteile sitzt
einfach nur mit dem pinsel
und dann kommt die fondant decke direkt
drüber jetzt muss ich sie kurz glatt
streichen
die überreste nehme ich dann mit einem
marzipan messer weg und kann die torte
dann komplett an der oberfläche gelitten
jetzt werde ich mit einem modell ihr
werkzeug bereits hier oben die
oberfläche etwas druck zu strukturieren
das soll er aussehen wie ein
aufgeschnittener baumstamm also zeichne
ich hier zum verringern
jetzt kommt der aufwendigste teil denn
jetzt kommt die rinde und zwar mache ich
die aus schottland oder nehme ich jetzt
immer so kleine stücke und knete weich
und dann vorm ich daraus eine kugel und
dann so einen langen strang deshalb
unten etwas dicker oben etwas dünner
man kann ich denn mit etwas essbarem
kleber ankleben
den kann man punktuell auftragen oder
großflächig so wie man das eben braucht
aber punktuell reicht hier auf jeden
fall ist sollte nur darauf achten dass
ihr oben auf jeden fall immer etwas
kleber mit habt dann einfach kurz an
drückten sie am anfang ziemlich lustig
aus und so unfertig aber es wird gleich
geht einfach erstmal mehrere an
und dann kann ich mit einer modelle
werkzeug die rinde etwas strukturieren
und zwar witzig die hier immer so ein
bisschen ein und verbindet dann auch
dadurch diese einzelnen elemente
miteinander
die rinde ist jetzt soweit komplett
jetzt muss hier oben noch abgeschnitten
werden denn der baum stand soll so
aussehen als wäre abgeschnitten also
muss er alles jetzt glattweg geschnitten
sein
jetzt struktur ich den baum noch ein
bisschen und zwar kann man hier außen
immer wieso kleine risse reinmachen mit
einem modell werkzeug und dann sitzen
wir hier noch namen ein okay was man
drauf schreiben und da vielleicht weit
genug da vielleicht ein der tollste was
drauf schreiben so was erlebt ihre mama
jetzt habe ich das eingeritzt und beim
einritzungen dieser buchstaben müssen
halt darauf achten dass davon nicht so
zu perfekt aussehen weil es muss so
aussehen als es in holz eingeritzt und
jetzt kann ich noch mit ein bisschen
farbe den ganzen baumstamm so ein
bisschen struktur geben dann sind noch
fertig
die torte ist jetzt fertig denen die
aktie habe ich jetzt einfach nur drauf
gelegt bislang nicht draufkleben außer
man wieder zitate irgendwo hin
transportieren dann sollte er sie
vielleicht reinstecken mit ein paar
zahnstochern und ich denke sie ist uns
ganz gelungen oder aber sagte außer
durch das jetzt nicht sally und samira
steht
nein das hat ein bisschen samira und
moral oder
und dann in seinem herz auch immer ich
möchte stück haben ja in leitete jetzt
direkt an dieser und lichtecht aus ganz
ehrlich und gerade heute wo wir so ein
baum schon machen hast du kein
holzfällerhemden
ja das ist das normalste ich jetzt
eigentlich ein karohemd genau wie ihr
das noch ich will nicht dass es
schneiden ich will durch sam schneiden
und alle sind gespannt wie sieht die
torte im innern auch so falls ihr euch
vielleicht fragt was es hier außen rum
ist das ist kein sand und auch kein
dreck ich habe einfach salzstangen und
oder kekse genommen und habe die
miteinander zerbröselt als er ist
einfach helle und dunkle kekse oder
salzstangen nehmen und dann habt ihr so
diese tolle farbe der leser nach ständig
die ganze zeit freue mich am meisten auf
den schulhof 107 mal ein interner der
kuchen ist sehr sehr saftig und das ist
ja so eine wickelt orte beim zweiten
stück chance war sie niemals mit und
saftig sehr frisch ist eine show
vonlanthen was ich hier oben ist ob
vanille schoko und vanille genau wissen
und ihnen kaffee genial wirklich genial
gut aus der immer noch
ja und die tat auch nicht zu lange
gedauert als ich habe gestern abend die
tröten gebacken und die cremes
vorbereitet und heute etwa sechs stunden
gedauert
mit drehen vielleicht ein bisschen
länger mit drehpause und hypnose aber es
ist wirklich eine tolle thema gut
nachmachen kann und auch handwerklich
jetzt nichts zu anspruchsvoll
danach machen wollt dann geht auf meinem
blog auf sales - blog.de da stets noch
mal ganz genau
vor allem stehen dann noch mal die
zutaten genau für diese torte und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei und
wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
biss dann tschüss und ihr 28 statt
einfach die kombi vanille schoko und
kaffee ist genial
was kann man machen wir kein café moskau
dann einfach nur vanille buttercreme
ciao